the other aspect of this is if we look
at Apple Qualcomm Samsung Huawei all use
the ARM architecture and yet the
performance of the systems varies I mean
I don't know whose opinion you take on
but you know Apple for some reason seems
to perform better and try these
implementations in architecture so
where's the magic and sure that happened
yeah so what arm pioneered was a new
business model as they said well here's
our proprietary instruction set and
we'll give you two ways to do it eat
there we'll give you one of these
implementations written in things like C
called Verilog and you can just use ours
well you have to pay money for that not
only pay will give you the you know will
license you to do that or you could
design your own and so we're talking
about numbers like tens of millions of
dollars to have the right to design your
own since they it's the instruction set
belongs to them so Apple got one of
those you know the right to build their
own most of the other people who build
like Android phones just get one of the
designs from arm and to do it themselves
so Apple developed a really good
microprocessor design team they you know
acquired a very good team that had was a
building other microprocessors and
brought them into the company to build
their designs so the instruction sets
are the same the specifications are the
same but they're hardware design is much
more efficient than I think everybody
else's and that's given Apple an
advantage in the marketplace and that
the iPhones tend to be the faster than
most everybody else's phones that are
there
you